all right so 50 shades i'm gonna throw
it to you to sort of kick it off bro
because i mean this was uh this was an
idea that you kind of cooked up so uh
where should we start with this one my
friend
well um as as you mentioned there is a
cottage industry that's popped up which
is nothing but just bashing women and
your premise from the get-go has been do
the work improve yourself and screen out
the red flags and the crazies and you'll
enjoy the fruits of your labor
and you know we just chit-chatting among
the group we figured out that there's a
lot of nice things women do
and when you get good quality women we
should preface that and that you know
that completely complements a man's life
um
is there any disagreement or anything
that we would need to expand on you know
the whole red flags because if you just
avoid those and that kind of solves a
lot of your problems to begin with
well i mean the only thing i would say
right is that sometimes don't get too
bogged down in the the red flag side of
the equation in in the sense of you know
sometimes guys have a checklist right
it's like oh my gosh like this girl you
know has like one or two like red flags
proceed with a little bit of caution
right depending on the nature of the red
flag because everybody's gonna have a
red flag if someone has no red flags
right that's a red flag in it of itself
so you know don't don't think that oh my
gosh like you know this girl has like
one red flag and otherwise like she's
awesome it's you know gonna be a total
write-off so that's something i hear a
lot from guys is that they send out well
one thing is up so they tend to hone in
on that one thing and make it a bigger
deal than it really is so you know
yeah so red flags right they're there
but you know proceed with caution and
everyone's going to have a red flag
just human nature right nobody's perfect
so you know proceed with caution right
if it's like hey her last one red flag
is oh she lit her apartment on fire okay
that's a pretty major one probably want
to stay away from that
minor like hey you know she
loves to watch garbage tv or like you
know play around on instagram all right
well then you know proceed with caution
right i thought i thought i made it
reasonably clear in the chapter when i
wrote it that like you can invite women
with red flags into your life it's just
that you're going to complicate it
unnecessarily
i mean yeah that was pretty clear but
again sometimes guys right they tend to
hyper focus right i'm like oh my gosh
like i saw this one thing and now i'm
like just waiting for it to pop up and
manifest and so sometimes you know being
guys we can like over complicate things
ourselves so you know when it comes to
the red flags again like take it all in
stride proceed with caution but um you
know don't let that stop you from right
enjoying the the company as somebody
that compliments you really well would
you would you agree with all that month
yeah i mean i think
context is important i think that
not giving into your knee-jerk reaction
unless it's something that's super
egregious like we talk about i mean the
number one that you would never
shouldn't should never and shall never
tolerate it's like a violent woman for
some for example yeah but we talk about
like daddy issues so some guys will say
like okay
uh her parents were divorced that's it
red flag done right okay let's do a
little bit of digging let's figure it
out okay maybe she has a
good albeit separate relationship with
each parent maybe he's still around or
because because even like we mentioned
and we talk about a lot like okay just
because your parents are still together
doesn't necessarily mean that this guy's
not a piece of furniture or he's not you
know catered to the whim of his uh cater
to his princesses every need and every
whim so uh yeah i i think it's one of
those things where you're kind of just
testing the ice
right you're giving it a couple of
knocks before you step onto that uh
iceberg and that ice flow so
yeah i think there are some that you can
essentially
dismiss right away
but
even something as simple as like tattoos
okay well i got these when i was really
young you had a woman on your show a
couple weeks back where she's like
covered head to toe i think
and it's like you know i really regret
these i wish i hadn't done that if i
know now what i knew then and
you could really
chalk that up to poor decision making
but
uh sometimes a lot of times people just
don't know any better and they're just
doing what they feel and especially when
emotions are the primary driver behind
women's decision making
uh they just maybe not know or won't
know until much later so yeah look like
some things are going to pop up proceed
with caution but
i think to renegade point like you're
never going to find
a no red flag or somebody that doesn't
take because look there's not just 20.
i'm sure that we could come up between
the four thousands more but those were
the ones that like popped right most
often over the last yeah and there are
some that are a little more egregious
than others and it just depends on what
you're gonna put up with and if you're
well equipped to deal with those too
some guys are more skilled than others
and they can know how to navigate that
so
so yeah i think generally speaking like
a good rule of thumb like
avoid red flags and that will get you
green flags but we can certainly it's
certainly more nuanced topic that we're
certainly going to get into
50 shades
yeah guys the you know as moft the green
the green flag things and the the things
that
you know when you when you engage
with a girl after screening out the
green flags and the things you start to
to get into and when we there was a
couple of us in the one percent met up
over the last couple of weeks and i said
to the guys they said if any of us
arrived here
to the house and said oh i just i i had
a i hit a deer on the way down or i had
a blowout in my tire the first thing
we'd all do is rip on them going you
know just just just guys the way we rip
on each other if if you you know if if
you come across a good woman you tell
her that situation you know you're gonna
get a beer a cup of tea a coffee or it's
all sitting the sofa you're going to get
a back rub and de-stress and oh you've
had a real crap day and you know
sometimes
you you know the the female sense
senses compared to the male senses when
when they are
a good woman in this sense you're in a
crap place they'll they'll compliment
you
um jaren i i see in the live okay there
he is i i dropped him on uh facebook for
a message here we go what's up buddy
i wasn't sure if you checked the message
but i saw you looking for the link
oh nice
can you can you hear me yeah yeah you're
coming loud and clear man
loud and clear so we're talking about
what a good wyman is today how you doing
man oh cool yeah i'm doing well
i've done all these calls but normally
i'm just laying on the couch with the
the headphones on and uh i've got a plus
one here and she's like i'm a
photographer all right go ahead and set
the shot while i shower real quick so
i like it yeah i like the light in the
background how are you guys doing i know
you don't care about the shot
that's all good man good
inside review for the audience we do uh
we do these bi-weekly calls and then
like for these shows we get and get uh
we do like the pre-show calls and
they're actually really fun we're like
setting everything up so that's all i
say i'll come in at least with a plug
for rich's group join the group there's
all sorts of fun stuff we do
you see guys like me moth josh on here
uh irish
we come in the group add a ton of value
we get invited on the shows like this
and before you know it you know we're
we're having actual like calls together
and playing and stuff out so super cool
guys just a little insider's view for
y'all so
what are the positives when it comes to
women because i mean
i feel like it's kind of obvious you
know whenever this you know conversation
comes up about you know like what's good
about women and there's a lot of guys
that are like down and out about it and
they're like it's just not worth it bro
she's just gonna steal all your money
break your heart and monkey branch over
to chad and you know you'll never see
your kids again and yeah that happens to
some guys but you know women do
compliment a man's life if uh
if you're a guy worthy of that one and
two you got you know strong framing you
know how to deal with a long-term
relationship you know with a woman in
your life i mean it is easier just
dating women spinning plates dating
non-monogamously than it is to deal with
one woman in a long-term relationship
um it's also lower risk you know um you
get the best of them too yeah really
nice yeah so i mean like i mean if you
do decide to
you know invite a woman into your life
and become exclusive in a you know like
relationship or not exclusive however it
is you know you decide to run it but if
you do invite into your life like you
should you should only be inviting a
woman really if if if she's a good chick
so what does a good woman look like to
you guys
i always say and guys join maf and i
after these shows we always do them it's
a little kind of like free flowing
format but um i always say to moss crowd
that it's collaborative rather than
combative and i have this conversation
with mexican girls all the time i
literally just had it in the last half
hour like why don't you date american
girls there's a lot of them down here
and i say you'll notice very clearly
like once you get to the point where we
start going out in public if you get to
that point with me um
like a lot of americans will come up and
talk to me and you'll notice very
clearly how they treat the american men
versus how like my mexican girls or even
girls that aren't mine treat me or like
mexican guys in general and that's
collaborative i think is a big one uh
for example i told you i have a plus
lunch took a little too long in the
shower so i'm like all right well now
i'm behind so you got to set up my shop
for me and she was she was out here
doing that and then now she put on her
makeup doing whatever so it's like hey
okay like i gave you a little bit of
space but now since i'm behind you need
to make it up to me and then there's no
there's no bickering there's no fighting
there's no whatever it's like oh yeah of
course my bad i didn't realize that like
okay cool yeah and it's nice it's fun
it's free-flowing and it's just i always
say again on mop show just a good
experience overall and i think a lot of
guys that don't have those experiences
it's because they tell these really
stupid stories to themselves like i
don't deserve a girl like this uh in our
private one percent call i got to that
point this week and i'm like oh
no i thought this girl's out of my you
know out of my league which a lot of
guys fall into that misnomer in their
head and then i realized no this chick's
into me like jaren be cool man and have
a good time and i think
women feminine women are able to do that
and again the key is collaboration verse
competition i believe
i just want to i just want to throw this
up on the screen real quick to deal with
it uh andy says i got permanently banned
for putting your five tips to be more
attractive in my profile
that's a twitter post that keeps getting
retweeted because it's popular and it's
like standard stuff like you know be
feminine know how to cook you know
compliment his life don't be
argumentative you know feminism
and girls will say no duh like if you
have like when girls like a lot of but i
mean like you can't put that in like a
tinder profile today especially if you
live in north america right like yeah
you will get banned off
but when you have that conversation
girls like so i checked out your videos
and i'm like yeah they're really
controversial they're like no they're
not like what are you talking about like
this is all no duh stuff and they
actually get stoked about it like we
wish more guys knew this stuff because
it's fun for them to be able to have
good experiences with guys too when you
both bring your best to the table it's
just it's just a joy all around that's
the funny thing too because i mean like
when you really knock this out of the
park
like women generally are like you're
you're actually providing a useful
service like you're showing guys how to
be attractive how to maintain frame how
to make bank and chase excellence right
like these are things that we put
emphasis on
yeah it benefits them at the end of the
day like let's be honest most women want
to date men and the more men that are
out there that get it you know they're
going to have better experiences yeah i
mean it's like to use a car example
right like if you just barely know how
to drive a toyota corolla and you throw
a ferrari at your way it's gonna be very
intimidating to be very scary you
actually might have like a really
terrible experience because you're not
gonna know what to do but you know you
get your driving skills up take a couple
race courses and suddenly you're getting
the most out of it it's pretty much like
that like when you as a guy right are on
your game and getting the most out of
life you're gonna find that you bring
the most out of women right because a
lot of guys don't know how they know how
to right engage and start talking to
girls but they don't know how to elicit
and bring out the best that they have to
offer and once you figure that out
suddenly everything else starts leveling
up in your life hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you